(audience clapping)
(upbeat country music)
♪ Boy, I've been thinking about us ♪
♪ And you know I ain't
good at this stuff ♪
♪ But these feelings piling
up won't give me no rest ♪
♪ This might come out a little crazy ♪
♪ A little sideways, yeah maybe ♪
♪ I don't know how long it'll take me ♪
♪ But I'll do my best ♪
♪ If you'll be my Louisiana ♪
♪ I'll be your Mississippi ♪
♪ You'll be my Little Loretta ♪
♪ I'll be your Conway Twitty ♪
♪ You'll be my sugar, baby ♪
♪ I'll be your sweet iced tea ♪
♪ You'll be my honeysuckle ♪
♪ I'll be your honey bee ♪
(upbeat country music)
♪ Your kiss just said it all ♪
♪ I'm glad we had this talk ♪
♪ Nothing left to do but
fall in each others arms ♪
♪ I could've said I love you ♪
♪ I could've wrote you a line or two ♪
♪ Baby, all I know to do is
speak right from the heart ♪
♪ If you'll be my soft and sweet ♪
♪ I'll be your strong and steady ♪
♪ You'll be my glass of wine ♪
♪ I'll be your shot of whiskey ♪
♪ You'll be my sunny day ♪
♪ I'll be your shade tree ♪
♪ You'll be my honeysuckle ♪
♪ I'll be your honey bee ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)